from one another
it
[Silence]
continuing in the chapter of patience
the 30 31st narration
offered by.
This is the narration of anis. This is
the third morning that we discuss this
same narration.
Again, due to the depth and immensity of
lessons and knowledge and wisdom found
in this narration, many of the points of
this narration,
if we were to employ in our lives and
ourselves, even a portion of them,
not only would we be fulfilling the
sunnah, following the sunnah, not only
would we be earning reward with
Allah, subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
But it would make our lives
much better, much easier.
And that is
lessons like
not trying to speak reason to raw
emotion.
Not rejecting
and arguing
merely by way of rejecting the messenger
who carries the message
like
apology and acceptance of apology. As
we'll see, the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam was owed an apology
and this woman came to apologize and he
did not
he sai was accepted that apology
etc. many lessons for us in this
narration that are beyond the mere scope
of the
title of the chapter which is patience.
There's a lot of other peripheral
lessons to be had.
So this is the narration of Annis. Again
this hadith has been collected by Bkari
Muslim
in which Annis states that
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
passed a woman who was crying at the
grave of a child that she was bererieved
of. So basically this was a young child
that passed away due to whatever
many reasons a child would pass away
from and she was bererieved. She was
obviously very
she was obviously in a lot of pain and
she was mourning and grieving the loss
of her child.
And so she was there at this grave. Now
this could mean that they had just
buried the child. Just buried the child.
And as many of us know, when you go to
a funeral
and the burial takes place and the
ground is the the grave is covered and
everything is finalized and finished,
people leave. And maybe she stayed
behind
at this grave long after everyone else
had left.
or this child had passed away
much earlier days ago and she was going
to visit this grave. What's the
difference?
What's the what does this does this make
any difference?
Well, it affects the
ruling that is taken from this issue and
that is, is it permissible for a woman
to follow a funeral procession or is it
permissible for a woman to visit the
cemetery and the graveyard?
And this is an issue that the scholars
and Islamic jurists have differed upon.
And the majority of the scholars
of the of the three of the four MH
view that it is permissible for a woman
to visit a grave
under the condition. Now there are
conditions here.
What are these conditions?
First of all, that she did do nothing
haram there at the grave such as
whailing and you know doing all of
these things or innovations or any
multitude of things that people do when
they visit a grave.
Number two, that she have the permission
of her husband or welli caretaker.
Number three, that
this not be
with any
means that there is no suspicion
attached to this visitation.
Where are you going? I'm going to visit
the grave of my brother. I'm going to
visit the grave of my father. when
really the cemetery during the prophet's
time sai wasallam in that time of jahyah
was a place where at night specifically
people would go to meet each other to do
bad things and so if there is any
reba if there is any suspicion meaning
it's during a suspicious time it's of a
of a suspicious frequency
It is under suspicious
circumstances. It is not permissible
and it must be with the permission of
her caretaker.
And some scholars add and this is
correct that it not be of
such frequency
that it goes beyond what is normal.
meaning that every day or every single
week or every 2 days she is going to
visit these graves or going to visit the
cemetery. It should not be something
that is extreme or very frequent.
There is a narration in
which the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
said
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has his curse
is upon the women that are constantly
going to visit the graves. Constantly
meaning exaggerated often often often
more than is acceptable more than is
appropriate.
Right?
And so
an occasional visit to the cemetery
for a woman under these conditions is
permissible.
Al Ahmed
and in the med of the former
viewed that it was impermissible due to
a number of evidences and that is an
opinion that has its strength and merits
to it. however we have here for
instance this narration is a an example
of women having gone to visit the graves
in the prophet's time saiam
and him not prohibiting them in an in an
a complete fashion meaning is absolutely
impermissible for a woman to go to a
grave. If that were the case during his
time, we wouldn't find instances like
this where women were at the cemetery
visiting the cemetery, etc. It's
something that did occur and it's
something that is permissible. However,
it is permissible under the conditions
that we just mentioned.
How about for a woman to follow a
funeral procession? This is more
more
specific than merely visiting the grave.
The majority of the scholars, the the
Jum meaning the majority of the form
are of the view that it is permissible
for a woman to visit the graves given
the conditions I just mentioned.
However, it becomes more specific
when it is going to follow a funeral
procession.
Is it permissible for a woman to follow
a funeral procession?
There is a narration where there was a
funeral to take place in the prophet's
time saiam.
and he passed by a group of women of the
companions that were preparing
themselves to go and follow the funeral
procession.
And so when he passed them, he asked
them,
"Where are you all planning to go?" They
said, "To follow the funeral
procession."
[Silence]
He said, "Go back to your homes,
sinful and unrewarded." Meaning that it
is not permissible for a woman to follow
a funeral procession. This narration is
not an authentic narration. It's been
collected in a sununin. It's been cited
as an evidence for the prohibition of a
woman following a funeral procession.
But it is a weak narration and a
weaker opinion. Is it permissible for a
woman to follow the a funeral
procession?
Permissible? Yes. In the correct
opinion,
preferable? Certainly not. It is not
especially
due to the
due to the circumstances that follow
a funeral procession. But if we were to
add to that
that which women are most pr prone to
during funeral processions such as
wailing and doing things that are of
the affairs of
anybody.
this whailing and screaming and doing
all these things that is most prevalent
amongst women in following a funeral
procession. This makes it absolutely
haram and it's not permissible for a man
or a woman to do such things and it's a
major sin in Islam. However, if the
previous
conditions are met and it is infrequent
for a woman to follow a funeral
procession, then the majority of the for
view that it is permissible.
Alhamdulillah.